a
[Música]
recuerdo que desde muy pequeña me
encantaba la música todas las mañanas al
despertar cantaba a viva voz la canción
de feliz cumpleaños o happy birthday to
you pues siempre fue una niña soñadora y
soñaba con ser como las chicas de la
televisión en la televisión veía muchas
series pero una en especial hannah
montana y en esta serie hay una canción
que se llama the best of both works lo
mejor de dos mundos este titulo define
mucho de lo que soy actualmente crece y
soñando a ser una estrella del pop pero
rodeada de una familia netamente andina
soy milián award una chica de 21 años
que ama la música desde siempre así en
lima perú en el año 2000 y tengo raíces
andinas en gallinas y apurimeñas canto
bailo creo contenido y compongo
canciones pero más que todo eso soy una
joven mujer peruana que se ha propuesto
la tarea de revalorar la cultura andina
latinoamericana a través de la cuestión
de la música para mostrar y celebrar mi
propia identidad hace tres años me
aventuré en el viaje del pop andino pero
que es el pop andino y como nací
para me cuenta que cuando estábamos con
mi productor empezando el proyecto
musical empezaron a conversar sobre
algunos temas y canciones de la música
andina y pues la sorpresa de todos fue
que yo conocí a muchas de estas
canciones y las cantabas como si siempre
las hubiese interpretado la cultura
andina llega a mí de forma totalmente
indirecta sin querer queriendo por las
canciones que cantaban mis abuelos por
las canciones que escuchaban mis padres
en los almuerzos las historias de sus
juventudes las festividades típicas los
platos que comíamos en casa el viaje del
papa andino comenzó cuando salió la idea
de hacer un proyecto musical una carrera
porque eso era lo que yo quería para mí
y ahí viene la pregunta qué mensaje
quiere es dar con tu música pues yo con
18 años nos va súper perdida pero decide
explorar el mundo de la fusión probar la
extraña y rara idea de ser una estrella
del pop pero en el perú y con lo mío con
algo que me identifique y me diferencia
todo mi primer año fue de aprendizaje
más guiado por lo que otros me decían y
me recomendaban hacer o ser porque no
sabía mucho y no tenía muchas ideas aún
o sí las tenía me daba vergüenza decir
más y pues me nutrí mucho aprendí mucho
y también descubrí que muy pocas veces
me sentía cómoda con lo que los demás me
recomendaban ser o hacer el estereotipo
de que como debería ser una cantante de
música fusión en el perú como por
ejemplo milena es una falta de respeto
cantar música andina vestida así milena
eres muy tradicional para tocar aquí
milena no existe un mercado de música
fusión en lima ni en el perú milena aún
no tiene media identidad musical milena
te falta mucho para aprender me le nada
porque si están dando covers o milena
capta más covers etcétera etcétera
etcétera para los demás preside
imposible el hecho de unir el pop que a
mí me gustaba con el que yo había
crecido el pop de britney spears de lady
gaga de one direction etcétera pues con
el mundo andino y en el 2019 algo cambió
decidí volar como y atreverte comencé a
poner en práctica mis propias ideas
recogí todo lo aprendido y a pesar del
miedo comencé a crear y aprobar y en
esta búsqueda de mi identidad musical me
encontré a mí misma porque la música
sale del alma en los experimentos me di
cuenta que esos dos mundos que todos me
decían que estaban súper separados no
estaban tan alejados como yo creía con
cada experiencia lograda fui haciendo un
cambio interior que se traducía en cada
composición o idea de fusión que fui
explorando a medida que me arriesgaba a
crear
interior hice un mensaje un mensaje
propio que salía de mi corazón y que
quise transmitir a las diversas personas
a las que pudiera llegar a través de las
redes sociales oa través de cada
presentación que tenía pues que somos
una mezcla estamos llenos de diversidad
cada uno de nosotros está hecho con una
fórmula diferente y en estas diferencias
están muchas veces nuestras mayores
riquezas y ese es mi caso y me aferré a
eso a esa idea local de ser una popstar
a mi manera y en mi realidad así todos
me dijeron que eso era súper difícil o
medio imposible pues sigo aquí cada día
con más vídeos y más bailes y lo más
importante disfrutando al máximo el
proceso
a medida que iba probando con mis
producciones musicales a pesar de los
estereotipos mucha gente empezó a
apoyarme ya utilizar mi música para
cantarla y bailar la recibí mensajes de
todo el mundo y dije amiga no es malo
ser diferente empecé a sentirme libre
como cuando era niña y todas las mañanas
cantaba al despertar a viva voz happy
birthday to you o feliz cumpleaños de
esta manera me encontré a través de mi
música descubrí que no necesito estar
dentro del estereotipo de nada ni de
nadie y que estamos en una época donde
hay tanta mezcla que es normal ser parte
de diferentes mundos a la vez que estos
mundos no están tan divididos como todos
me han hecho creer y que la misma prueba
de eso soy yo
identidades mixtas orgullo y amor por
nuestras raíces en las nuevas
generaciones no tenemos que negar de
dónde venimos para poder ser quiénes
queremos ser entendí que soy única y al
igual que yo me convencí de mi propia
identidad y de mis orígenes vi la
oportunidad de proveer identidad a
muchos jóvenes y niños vez de mi ilusión
la fusión de la música andina con
sonidos pop latin reggae rock etcétera
etcétera etcétera a lo que bauticé como
pop andino mi música crece conmigo y me
está llevando en un viaje maravilloso
donde sin duda el mayor logro que he
tenido es descubrir quién soy este ha
sido mi historia y ahora te quiero
invitar a ti a que pueda ser libre de
amar y descubrirte a ti mismo ya tus
orígenes para que puedas encontrar tu
propia fórmula
a
[Música]